alors pour terminer cette émission avec
sur une note un peu plus gaie avec
tintin qui est un personnage
effectivement qui a été qui a été
contesté alors vous aussi je vous pose
la même question fasciné par hergé ou
par tintin comme vous voudrez fasciné
admiratif
vous avez de l'affection un peu des
trois mèches commencerait surtout par
l'affection
ils ont que j'ai lu tintin jeunes je les
laissais tomber pendant un certain
nombre d'années
et puis j'ai de leur prix plus tard avec
avec affection mais vous avez transmises
aux littératures à harvard c'est
incroyable et professeurs littérature
harvard qui écrivent 250 pages 300 pages
sur sur tintin c'était quand même et
détonante
oui mais ça veut pas dire qu'on est
sérieux 24 heures sur 24
bon alors c'est vrai que tintin a été
très très contestée vous citez
d'ailleurs des textes où on le traite de
alors là aussi antisémite raciste alors
rg au départ l'origine de tintin c'est
une origine extrêmement précise hergé
était un jeune homme de 22 ans qui
travaillait dans un journal catholique
de droite maurrassien ils connaissent m
aura sûrement moins bien que monsieur
boutant ghm et au moins ils le
connaissaient bien et le prêtre qui
dirigeait ce journal l'abbé wallez a
demandé à hergé de faire un supplément
pour les jeunes qui reflèterait sous
forme de dessin les idées du journal et
c'est comme ça que hergé a été amené à
créer tintin et dans la première image
du premier tintin on voit tintin qui
part pour la russie avec l'abbé wallez
qui l'accompagnent à la gare et qui lui
dit mon cher ami enquêtait bien et puis
voilà ça démarre comme ça parce que vous
les montrer dans ce livre c'est qu'il ya
des métamorphoses dans le personnage n'a
pas physiquement ils ne changent pas
mais sa pensée évolué oui oui c'est à
dire que tintin il a vécu cinquante ans
il a peut-être vieilli quatre ans mais
il a vécu ce pendant 50 ans et il a
quand même
hergé a connu un succès commercial
énorme et qui est dû
en grande partie à son talent est aussi
en partie au fait qu'il a su adapter son
personnage à la mentalité contemporaine
avant la guerre de 40 donc tintin était
plutôt un défenseur des idées de droite
et après la guerre de 40 petit à petit
il a évolué vers une espèce de
libéralisme bontin jusqu'à n'ont pas
vraiment renier mais tourné le dos à ses
premières valeurs vous montrer c'est que
que soit la première partie de la
deuxième partie il représente le bien
des français bien il est toujours du
côté du bien
même au début ils s'identifient lui même
bien il est lui-même le bien il est la
patrie les la nation il il est le bien
et puis petit à petit après le bien est
incarnée dans un autre personnage au
moins dans les premiers tintin jusqu'au
sceptre d'ottokar le bien c'est le roi
au début et plus après à cause
probablement d'ailleurs de la guerre et
de l'évolution personnelle d'hergé est
bien prêt il ya plus bien du tout alors
au début c'est simple c'est manichéen il
ya le bien d'un côté le mal de l'autre
mais après prenez par exemple la sphère
tournesol haddock et tintin sont dans
l'ambassade de bordures à rôle et
haddock demande à tintin qu'est ce qu'on
doit faire
où sont les méchants alors tintin lui
dit mais vous allez les reconnaître ils
ont une sale tête et haddock regarde les
espions bordure d'un côté les espions
syldave de l'autre ils ont tous les deux
la même salle tête
alors ils trouvent la solution il prend
leur tête et il est à plat comme ça l'un
contre l'autre ya plus de bien il ya
plus de mal il ya plus qu un espèce de
deux champs neutre et alors devant cette
absence de bien et de mal et bien qu'est
ce que fait un teint il se retira
moulinsart et y mène sa vie tranquille
il va cultiver son jardin peu hot
rapprochement entre morat c est un passé
que maurras avec le culte de jeanne
d'arc
d'ailleurs c'est le seul moment vous
mettez en colère dans votre livre vous
en prenez à l'historien le goff bon et
vous dites
et vous dites que que tintin ils
possèdent en commun avec l'héroïne de
domrémy le courage la jeunesse et la
virginité
oui
avi je crois que l'héroïne de domrémy a
été canonisée peu de temps avant que
hergé a créé tintin et qu'il a été
influencé par tintin fête qui sera
canonisé ainsi possible c'est pas
impossible
à la fin il fait preuve d'agnos this is
mais je crois que l'église ne le
canonisera pas en face ça m'étonnerait
mais en tout cas
en tout cas j'ai en tout cas c'est vrai
que tintin de chasse dont lui connaît
pas du tout petit ami et il est un héros
et il entend des voix pas des voix
d'ange ou de saint si vous voulez mais
la voix de sa conscience qui lui dit va
combattre le mal partout où ils se
trouvent
alors il va en russie d'abord et puis
ensuite il va en amérique parce que ces
deux pays représentent le mal au moins
au début pour lui
vous avez vous êtes quand même pas envie
mais en même temps extraordinairement
sérieux vous êtes un peu psychanalyste
veut un petit peu référence à freud
continuelle et vous dit ceci avec le
plus grand sérieux l'oreille cassée
quitter vos albums évidemment de tintin
leurrer cassez met en place les
fondements d'une anthropologie tin tin
yens même le faire un sa colère j'ai
souligné
bon tu sérieux d'accord une
anthropologie tatillonne oui c'est à
dire que ce que j'ai voulu dire par là
c'est que mon hypothèse
en relisant comme adultes les aventures
de tintin c'est que ça formait un petit
monde complet en soi donc qui
fonctionnait selon des règles
or tout le monde le sait dans 20 ans il
n'y a ni échanges monétaires ni sexe n'y
a pas de sexe il ya pas de monnaie c'est
à dire les deux des principales choses
de la vie des adultes sont absentes
mais si le monde de tintin est un monde
complet on doit sans doute trouver des
attitudes des réactions des choses si
vous voulez des comportements qui
tiennent lieu de ça c'est en ce sens que
j'ai voulu parler d'une anthropologie
tin tin yens parce que c'est des règles
ou sait si vous voulez des choses que
hergé inventé lui même pire vous aimez
évidemment analysé l'inconscient de
l'oeuvre d'hergé à travers haddock
tournesol dupont et dupond et là je veux
dire qu'on apprend des choses il avant
le malheureux hergé il irait ça il
serait absolument
dès que vous avez découvertes france le
personnage favori
un donc est atteint oui mais vous
trouvez que tintin c'est plus à lui
creusé hergé rouge tout est au beau fixe
avec freud est en fugue depuis le livre
qui adorent ya quelques années lamu
statut on sait que freud a manigancé
tout son système pour cacher une
histoire de son père qui voulait pas
montrer ce texte 478 passionnant alors
je trouve que c'est très sérieux plus
que freud et quand on se dit alors il
m'a beaucoup amusé les histoires lacombe
la confusion tout dans l'histoire de 10
10 la saint jean
la confusion entre la tête el fallah
sinsat nous paraît un peu cherché
tellement fréquent maintenant
l'intérieur voilà voilà par exemple
chercher dans le dictionnaire tigana
sait plus dans quel album la quête de
data se présente comme un regret sus à
du terrain un retour à l'origine
l'entrée de la grotte représente à la
fois la bouche de la montagne son oeil
et son sexe car ils possèdent la forme
triangulaire d'un sexe féminin armé de
son piolet de son appareil photo tintin
il pénètre alors évidemment le sexe
féminin est pas tellement ridicule arg
hydroliennes surpris quand même oui ça
et je sois surpris dans la mercerie
l'homme a été surpris qu'il aurait sans
doute pas entériner ce genre de choses
mais il faut que vous compreniez ce
n'est pas seulement une boutade il faut
que vous compreniez que hergé a voulu
faire une oeuvre qui était une
initiation une oeuvre religieuse même si
à la fin de sa vie ne croyait plus en
dieu
il a quand même conservé une mentalité
religieuse et la plupart de ses albums
se sont voulus une initiation alors de
ce côté là je les analyse et comme
initiation mais en même dans cet univers
où il n'y a pas eu de femme par exemple
où il ya pas si c'est à questa fior et
vus par une augmentation
parlez-moi la castafiore bon alors
d'accord passons à la castafiore la
castafiore c'est la première vraie femme
qui entre dans l'univers d'hergé
elle arrive seulement à la fin elle
arrive quand les relations comme
l'attend est ce que vous ne comparez pas
la fameuse tente du début il ya une
espèce de danseurs de la gamme produits
à la tendance est à l'arrêt dans les
aventures de tact et connaissances vers
lui et oui bien sûr dans les mains du
comptage et des enfants des
petits-enfants
comment voulez-vous il m'oblige à lui
atteint
non tintin la castafiore elle ne vient
où elle ne fait son trou si je puis dire
parce que elle apparaît la castafiore
des les sept boules de cristal même pas
belle sceptre d'ottokar et la première
chose que tintin fait il a fui dans les
sept boules de cristal c'est exactement
la même chose
haddock et tintin la cuy et milou se met
à aboyer comme un fou quand elle se met
à chanter et dans la sphère tournesol
quand ils sont en bordure y est qu'ils
assistent à l'opéra les bijoux de faust
à l'opéra de fausses
si vous avez bien remarqué tintin a mis
un mouchoir bleu autour de la gueule de
milou pour l'empêcher de crier comme il
avait crié dans les sept boules de
cristal alors pendant très très
longtemps il fuit la castafiore
elle est absolument pour eux un monstre
la femme trop envahissante et puis après
justement la sphère tournesol à partir
du moment où elle est cachée dans sa
penderie
à partir du moment où elles des sceaux
et bien ils l'admettent bon gré mal gré
à moulinsart et là elle entre à
moulinsart et elle met la pagaille c'est
à dire vous parler de nous parler de la
sexualité refoulée de la castafiore
oui c'est vrai j'aurais lorsqu'elle
apparaît quand même pas beaucoup et vous
voyez quel et sexualité refoulée tout
vous êtes formidable histoire du pied le
pied du capitaine haddock absolument
écouter sans vouloir jouer au
psychanalyste amateurs vous remarquez
quand même que la castafiore
elle a quand même un comportement
complètement hystérique at elle prend le
doigt du capitaine haddock et elle lui
dit une petite poupée pour le pauvre
marin elle arrive au à moulinsart la
première chose qu'elle fait c'est mettre
ses mains sur les yeux du capitaine et
elle lui dit coucou et c'est elle une
arrière de bijoux oui elle n'arrête pas
de perdre ses bijoux elle n'arrête pas
de commettre des délits plus de faire
des actes manqués et gelé interprété -
dans ce sens là donc comme une
hystérique c'est à dire une personne
dont la sexualité un peu bloquée
jean-philippe domecq un mot sur tintin
vous aimez pain
oui évidemment on a tous été formés par
sa prépa par morath mais par un solide
renonce à ce genre ce genre d' analyse
n'empêche pas pendant ce temps là de
prendre le plaisir qu'on pouvait
éprouver lorsqu'on commencée l'étoile
mystérieuse et qui faisait si chaud dans
la rue et que les gens descendent et en
pyjama que le bitume fondé des caramels
mous que c'était hier ce genre de
travail ne tient en rien les que le
tapage fait d'ailleurs se dit maintenant
que robespierre terminé j'en ai jusque
là que vous apprécierez tintin oui oui
beaucoup
c'est tous des je crois que le travail
de monsieur post hallyday c'est vraiment
très intéressant parce que précisément
il va au coeur de l'idéologie tatin et
l'idéologie tata est important puisque l
élu c'est un livre qui délivre qui sont
lus par des 110 millions et millions
d'exemplaires et et je crois que c'est
une réflexion sur le rôle de la bande
dessinée à notre époque dans cette
civilisation de transition entre l'écrit
et l'oral et l'audiovisuel qui fait la
bande dessinée est tellement importante
et finalement tintin et idéologique
tatin sont certainement aussi important
que l'idéologie de maurras pour
l'information jeunesse contre lille est
pour terminer quels sont vos trois
albums préférés de tintin eh bien je
dirais l'album de l' aventure de la
licorne
l'album du temple du soleil et peut-être
aussi tintin au tibet mais j'aime aussi
beaucoup les bijoux de la castafiore
albigeois que ça disons que c'est plus
intellectuel les vieux de la castafiore
les autres sont sans doute les plus
émouvants et les plus ceux pour lesquels
j'ai le plus de tendresse
très bien merci alors quelques ouvrages
pour terminer à jussy